si el proceso criminal más grande de la
historia de francia 1800 partes civiles
300 abogados 150 periodistas un tercio
de ellos son extranjeros yo ya me
encuentro al interior de la corte de
justicia de parís y te puedo decir que
el presidente de la sala está en este
momento pasando lista a los acusados
recordemos que en total son 20 pero hay
6 que están ausentes por lo tanto son 14
11 de ellos que están presos están en un
box muy vigilado y tres de ellos están
sentados a delante de ese box y
justamente tocó el turno a sala gades
lahm el único sobreviviente de los
comandos del 13 de noviembre recordemos
que eran tías terroristas sólo él no
activos y cinturón de seguridad es una
de las grandes dudas de este proceso
cuando se le preguntó a él la profesión
porque les preguntan el nombre la fecha
de nacimiento de dirección en fin para
verificar la información él dijo que no
tenía profesión que él había dejado para
hacer combatiente del autodenominado un
grupo estado islámico se le preguntó
también el nombre de su madre y de su
padre él dijo los nombres de ellos no
tienen nada que hacer aquí y agregó que
solamente ala es el único dios que
existe y qué ya me dijo el mago mag es
su mensajero así que logran lo que más
espera este proceso justamente santiago
es saber si finalmente salas de slam va
a explicar lo que pasó es lo que buscan
sobre todo las víctimas civiles y bueno
el que haya hablado el que haya ya hecho
estas declaraciones quizás es un indicio
de que va a ser un juicio en que
finalmente se va a escuchar un
testimonio de salas de slam que hasta
ahora en todos los procesos que ha
participado ya sea el belga o en su
detención en francia nunca ha hablado
más que de religión